hey y'all i know a lot of you wanted a  full loft tour i know a lot of you think  it's absolutely insane that i have two  floors in my bedroom and honestly i  think it's pretty insane now too the  problem is this part of my room  literally has nothing up here i've  thought about putting a desk or a table  maybe but i really just use it for  storage but this is where the magic  happens this is my content creation  studio i can literally spend hours up  here behind this curtain there is  another area and this is where i'll sit  down maybe plan out and write my videos  and i have to turn the light on first  but behind that curtain there's actually  a tunnel